so und herzlich willkommen zur zweiten
vorstellung wie immer bzw wie letztes
mal auch wenn ihr es jetzt auch wieder
schafft das morgen die 1750 likes
erreicht sind
dann kommt übermorgen wieder eine also
endlich übermorgen also dann kommt
morgen wieder eine wenn sie jetzt noch
einige fragen hey du hat man die
gleichen waffen kämpfen
ich nehme das direkt untereinander auf
die sache war nur dass ich das halt erst
hochladen wenn man dem einen video 3500
like sind wir müssen dann halt gucken
wie lange wir das durchhalten sich neben
jetzt ein paar sachen auf und laden dann
hoch wenn ihr das erreicht habt also
wenn ihr wirklich viele sachen haben
wollt dann bleibt halt also hört sich
jetzt total wir hin dort an aber ist
also eine kleine herausforderung so
kommen wir zum heutigen zeit ich gehe
wieder auf creative blase der sieht ist
so kann ich einen film wartet dann geht
noch mal um ein textdokument so da habe
ich nämlich abgespeichert so hier
und zack - 56 86 88 68
die haben so eine telefonnummer nenne
ich mal es dfds oder ganz einfach sdf
movie ist weg.de create your world
ihr müsst das nicht so nennen also das
sagen wir fragen mich auch mal welche
muss ich jetzt auch so nennen
nein ihr müsst nur ball zieht das so
nennen ich guck wieder in den bildschirm
rein obwohl da die linse ist
hey hey fünf profis neues preissystem
street sich denn hier so schwarz das war
die kuh es ist ein zieht wo ein wenig
landschaften vorkommen und zwar nach
menschen muss die welt erst mal aufbauen
das ist das problem wenn man nebenbei
renne das dann minecraft braucht jahre
das bei meinem neuen pc hier lag das
immer noch so ein wenig also dass born
halt ca hier so in unserem wald und ihr
müsst euch eigentlich gar keine
koordinaten merken wir könnten jetzt
sagen ja fliegt im westen aber ihr müsst
einfach hier in die steppe fliegen wenn
ich das mal und dann kommt ihr direkt
auf ein npc dorf das geil da ist auch
eine schmiede so schauen wir mal was in
der schmiede drin ist surprise surprise
das übrigens auch so einen kürbis also
wer jetzt nichts anders werden was
explodiert oder so der fun fact
minecraft guy platz 4 gekauft hat kommt
ja sehr gut an minecraft schreibt mir
die kommentare ob ich davon etwas machen
soll
er weiß ja dass mittlerweile der welt
besser mittlerweile dass kürbisse
seltener sind als diamanten das heißt
hier sind nicht so geile sachen dann auf
jeden fall schonmal standard equipment
mit einem eisen schwert womit wir hier
so ein paar villiger töten können und
halten bei 7 oxidieren das ist ja auch
nicht also damit kann man zwar schon
portal machen und dann einfach in den
neckar reisen
so jetzt fliegen wir weiter in hier
ungefähr ja genau hierhin und zwar da ja
dieses kleine dörflein gefunden und wenn
wir hier weiterhin fliegen los jetzt
mache ist hier noch ein dorf direkt
nebeneinander leute dort nie geil
also ihr könnt ihn wahrscheinlich mit
einem weg einfach miteinander verbinden
das wäre schon kinder mit einer mine
kartbahn oder so dann sagt ihr mit viel
fantasie ist das eine straßenbahn also
hier ist noch ein dorf da ist allerdings
nichts interessantes sind einfach nur
zwei dörfer direkt nebeneinander quasi
nachbarstädte ist wirklich nichts
besonderes also das nicht eine schmiede
sein oder sogar ist halt nur so relativ
viele felder noch ein bisschen etwas
größeres dorf und natürlich direkt am
sandstrand bzw wüste auch genannt
wir können dann allerdings durch die
wüste durchfliegen was sehen wir hier
ein witches hat also ein hexen
hexenhäuschen die hexe war vorhin im
test nicht da nächst immer noch nicht da
hier haben wir natürlich ein paar sachen
wie dieses komische caudron oder hier
sondern maxime talbot ich hier bin kann
ich gar nicht aufnehmen alles mögliche
sachen haben wir hier auch noch in der
in dem sumpf beziehungsweise in dem
which is hat die mutter wenig gefunden
wenn ihr sie findet dann könnte eine
video einfach posten allgemein wenn wenn
ich jesus vorstelle und ihr da irgendwie
sogar diese hält er den maschen so
komisch der alles klar zu kommen ich mir
aber schon schonten allgemeinen wenn ihr
hier in den zelten immer ein bisschen
was was macht sage ich mal so ein
bisschen herum baut das war jetzt
letztes mal der fall zum beispiel wenn
hier die beiden dörfer verbindet und
dann richtig fetten bahnhof dahin baut
oder so können wir das gerne als video
antwort senden die geilsten sachen nehme
ich dann auch immer mal an sonst video
antworten kommt nur kaka aus amerika an
von wegen hacker basketball dings
gemacht hier nimm das anblasen dieser
scheiß nicht so geil wenn das von euch
konnte mit liebe gemacht dass dann nehme
ich das natürlich gerne an was ihr euch
auch noch zeigen wollte war das da
hinten kein kann ich ein geiles eine
geile landschaft das hab ich
herausgefunden
und zwar sind die krass schwarze wolken
am himmel
nee also das hat jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht so viel mit denen mit dem pc
dürfen ganzen quatsch zu tun
jetzt nur aufgefallen dass man da auf
jeden fall eine coole sache auch hin
bauen könnte
moment ich versuche ganz kurz zu zeigen
wo war denn jetzt weiter tier schon
hier war noch nicht viele war das hier
schon einen e mail nehmen ich glaube das
war weiter hier also das sieht auf jeden
fall hier schon kinder aus so einzelne
berge da drin oder alles hier
ich glaube ja genau hier war dass das
sieht mich echt schön hier ausfindig so
warte ich lande jemand ganz kurze
drittel also da erst mal so ein gebirge
wartet bodyguard noch auf daher genau
das am gebirge ja wie immer so ein paar
wasserstellen hier ist eine wasserstelle
da ist eine wasserstelle
die haben wir auch noch ein paar berger
sie kann man bestimmt was cooles
hinzaubern vor allem weil hier noch
diese dieses diese wien
stronghold keine stuff ist und hier kann
man auf jeden fall ist also wenn euch
das sieht gefallen hat dann gebt einfach
einen daumen hoch 2007 500 1750 likes
kommt morgen direkt noch eine sieht
vorstellung also wenn ihr das schafft
dann kommt das auch direkt und dann wird
es einfach zu sagen so ich wollte gerade
wieder meine hand einfach sogar
reinschmeißen in die kamera dann nehme
ich mir einfach immer die hand nehmen
hier die kettensäge die ich hier direkt
neben mir liegen habe und mir dann
einfach ab und holly dann immer direkt
einfach gegen die kamera also müsste ja
auch mal probieren das eigentlich ganz
gut ich denke ich bilde mir ein dass der
bildschirm schwarz wird aber naja also
ein wirklich kann nur die zeit
überbrückt und euch diese schöne bilder
zu zeigen jetzt des ntc dorf